in polymerase the weaker gymnastics
class for seniors is where the older
generation meets up many of them
experienced the crash of the American
b-52 bomber almost 50 years ago but no
longer want to talk about it they say
that ever since the incident their
village has been wrongly cast in a bad
light in Palomares people are full of
energy and love to dance
they've eaten lots of healthy fruit
because agriculture has always
flourished here the Sun shines and we
have wonderful beaches people should
come here to enjoy our region not to
criticize the thing with the bombs
because that scares tourists away but
for many villagers there's no getting
away from the past every day Maria
Flores passes by the restricted area
here in the middle of the village the
soil is contaminated with plutonium
residents have been waiting four years
for the site to be cleaned up now 83
Flores was pregnant back in January of
1966 that was when a u.s. b-52 bomber
collided with an aerial refueling tanker
and crashed over polymerase what an
explosion I thought everything was going
up in flames and that we'd all be burned
alive over here and collapsed in fear I
was dizzy with fear I was half dead I
thought it's the end of the world it's
all over Maria
the fishing village and most of
Andalusia narrowly avoided a major
nuclear disaster
the b-52s for hydrogen bombs didn't
detonate but two of the weapons
scattered highly radioactive plutonium
when they hit the ground the
environmentalist Marcos das believes the
handling of this nuclear incident one of
the most serious of the Cold War is
scandalous he says both the Americans
and the Spanish government downplayed
the danger and hoped the accident would
soon be forgotten but recent
measurements at the crash site show at
least a half a kilo of plutonium is
still irradiating the soil that's more
than in the area around Chernobyl the
site of the 1986 nuclear disaster but
until now there's only one thing here
keeping people out a chain-link fence
environmental activists have filed an
official complaints against the
authorities in charge complaint is that
they've left Europe's biggest nuclear
graveyard exposed for five decades and
until just a few years ago without any
monitoring at all these areas were used
as farmland as grazing land and water
reservoirs for farming were built here
even though they knew the soil was
contaminated to this day vegetables are
grown next to the restricted area
agriculture remains the region's most
important source of income but it's not
just the peppers and snow peas that are
regularly tested for radioactivity this
farmer herself travels to Madrid once a
year to undergo medical tests but Maria
sabe OTA is no longer afraid of the
routine check-up she has faith in the
statistics which so far don't indicate
an elevated risk of cancer Nino we
haven't had any babies born with
deformities or other problems
you know there's cancer here just like
in other places but that's a problem
around the world it's market day in
Pella modest word has spread that
thousands of tons of contaminated soil
will be dug up and shipped to the US
some locals are skeptical others are
angry they wanted to take the soil right
away fifty years later it's still here
now they want to stir everything up
again my husband and I don't think much
of that many here are against it but
Markos das says that further delays will
only increase the danger he believes
that some of the contaminated soil has
already been washed into the sea by the
rain and wind
I found that radioactivity in this part
of the Mediterranean is 20 times higher
than average that suggests a significant
amount of plutonium is already in the
sea we need to do more research on this
to cleaning up the designated zones
isn't enough we need to know if Moore's
being contaminated
but few here are interested in
discovering the truth the fishermen and
farmers would rather it be swept under
the carpet and so would the tourism
industry these holiday homes were built
close to the contaminated area it's
unlikely that the buyers were told about
the radioactive soil on their doorstep